[Music]
and got cotton news submitted by freaks
and geeks oh I never got into that show
what's freaks and geeks to show about
freaks and geeks
it was an old TV show where all the
Apatow crew came up John Francis Daley
Seth Rogen James Franco perhaps you
heard of these folks yeah I have yeah
his laugh makes me so happy I love his
laugh feels like a teddy bear yeah makes
the angels are hurting to me it's so
happy if you don't like him I can blows
the Pineapple Express yeah that was a
really [ __ ] funny that was a grand
idea for me it was film in Downey huh oh
really parts of it in Downey whoa cause
like there's parts like where he's
driving and I'm like that was the one
film I think he did that really really
like the windshield kicking like the
main yeah yeah I like this is the engine
oh [ __ ] what's [ __ ] home you don't
believe in the end of the world not the
way they did it oh you don't think a big
giant [ __ ] demon like 60 stories tall
has a huge big swinging dick and just
[ __ ] everything out a globe-trotting
influencer was busted while on vacation
for ties to a money-laundering scheme
how come everybody gets into money
laundering how do you get into this how
do you get into money Lana I'm saying
who knows someone that's trying to get
into money line let me know this person
I have no idea what the [ __ ] you're
talking to me neither a lot of like
especially reddit people hate
influencers yes I love it they're always
like influencers are the worst [ __ ]
people though influencers it sounds
really bad already
no but it's just like you do realize
this has been going on for like years
right like forever and ever like
billboard models so that's technically
influencers and influencing people I
know but it's built into the name right
like it's like how Bobby in England gets
laughed at because they're called
Bobby's I could silly mmm so what would
you prefer they're called I don't know
[ __ ] boys honestly
I'd rather that I would because
influencers just sounds like you think
you're the [ __ ] didn't give themselves
the name I didn't know what we were
called until people emailed yeah I
didn't give myself this name well I know
you didn't they tried a bunch of [ __ ]
when I was at maker inside those rooms
they would try [ __ ] like tastemaker and
I was like oh you have no idea what
would you prefer
writer yeah [ __ ] alright but even
that content YouTube person whose only
wit written YouTube videos and they call
themselves a writer it's like dad okay
content creator sure I'm cool with that
that's the least kanji one from you but
people are just there against the whole
like well she's promoting products so is
every other company in the whole entire
know for sure that's fine
or work but just calling herself an
influencer like that dead like that
dumb [ __ ] Jade girl whatever Olivia
Jade or whatever no idea that [ __ ] is
exactly the college the time I was like
in one person exactly why we all hate it
so she she got into college but she
didn't want to go to college and she's
like I just like to promote products and
like me like tell people what to wear
and [ __ ] pretty like vacant and vapid
and [ __ ] yeah
there's a market for people like it so
Who am I to judge
I'm like I don't mind the word but I
think people hate that both these girls
are pushing products and I think their
Instagram is the hottest [ __ ] volleyball
I'm like well the thing is it works
that's why people make people like and
that's what Michael Jordan did that's
what everyone did yeah that's what
everyone has been doing since the
beginning of Michael Jordan was Nancy
right mm-hmm
now imagine calling Michael Jordan link
yeah it just sounds weird this is
definitely a new key like a new term I
wish they just called you an instagramer
or a youtuber or a [ __ ] Viner like
they used to write like I don't know why
everyone has to get an advanced about it
I call 2020 mmm content creator it's a
good content creator I just like my name
what's my name did write a vyd only
thing just call me the bastard you are
the butler
Estados the bartender fast and
dude because I was at playlist live in a
there's a kid walking around his name
was like jacket kid or something about a
lot exactly exactly but I feel like that
kid should get jumped you're right so
his name is the backpack kid and like I
can just see him ten years from now
being in a playlist thing or VidCon
thing and he's like hey back 40 years
old I went to one of those events where
they have a bunch of influencers come so
we could see if we like their products
maybe we could take photos with it in
whatever which I was like [ __ ] it why
not so I brought an aerial - so she got
a bunch of free [ __ ] mm-hmm but it was
so weird because that's somebody hired
next to you to walk around with your
name tag like this look at the guy I was
like put that [ __ ] down dude like you're
making me feel uncomfortable
put it down relax you know because they
have to there hi there to hold our bag
so [ __ ] demeaning look at them I was
like you don't have to hold my bag he
goes I have to I literally have to a
sidewalk didn't put put your arms down
and don't hold my sign it makes me feel
terrible right so I guess like they
that's what they're hired to do so they
set some I'll hold a sign and then hold
our bags at the same time and I'm like a
bro just [ __ ] relax like your arms
are gonna die out before this event ends
yeah you know but then I started looking
up something you gotta have any bags
they go up and they just start throwing
stuff beautycon crazy that's what it's
so it looks like one of those types of
things and so like the weird thing was I
I saw the name tags of people there and
these are like the people that are kind
of walking around like they're the [ __ ]
it's like [ __ ] 3,000 followers or
thousand followers like they literally
nobodies Wow
I got invited through my agency so these
people are probably they want to be
actors or actresses uh but I've never
seen a somebody who has done nothing
treat other people like they owe them
everything that's great hold back that
kids a dick I just think that that would
be great
cuz he's like on the backpack kid who
thought [ __ ] are you really nice kid
though you know he could be I just think
the name is so silly and all this shit's
good for me and you want to jump in
music well it's just because I see his
photos yeah I saw a couple of photos and
it's like it's call most like I'm the
[ __ ] yeah does that mud fee you know but
I'm like you would have to
done that's how I feel about the
yodeling kid does it yodeling good yeah
but he's a singer though he records
records says he like well he has
concerts now - he's like recording
records so I could see his talent the
backpack kid is somebody I'm like what
what female models you know they're
doing [ __ ] you know I mean they gotta
get everyone's do it everyone's doing it
and it's on Forna is like one of the
most iconic dances on for tonight and
for soda Soulja Boy but at least he's
making music you see at least Soulja
Boy's make it [ __ ] moves making
[ __ ] Nintendo consoles ripping off
[ __ ] China if I would have came out
like now like this time and became a
fortnight dancer or for daddy was doing
for tonight because he took which dance
that they take from the floss the floss
analysis from backpack boy not Soulja
Boy oh I thought we were talking about
that I could see how you get a confused
you just say the [ __ ] with normally it's
so funny I'm eating on it because he's
more successfully from doing one thing
yeah and then amazing yeah it's really
what it is this girl here 26 my name is
Jenny Jenny
so she's a University of Miami graduate
as she faces moneylender laundry
blundering meandering charges because
investigators say that they have
uncovered this crazy web of corruption
at the Colombian ports of Buenaventura
where her father was employed as a
customs officer and so they're saying
that he pocketed more than a million
dollars in bribes to allow untaxed goods
into the country they always be caught
man and she cover it up by being an
influence influence so I don't know like
they don't ever mention how many
followers she had or whatever the [ __ ]
but they are calling her an influencer
and saying that she like posted stuff on
her social media accounts but I don't
know what the PM what's her what's her
ratio I'll take a look at this so now
let's do this I don't know what does she
look like naked let me see this yeah
how are her captioning oh wait that's
the wrong one but yeah they're just
saying that she would always post a
whole bunch of photos of her and like
her lavish lifestyles lavish that's
everybody I don't know
I love which guy it's a guy named its
lavish oh wow she doesn't look like one
of those influencers we're not really
whoa look at that let me see your face
look she doesn't dress the part for me
or dad I'm assuming her mom's but this
is the guy that is also my laundry yeah
like he's the one that's getting turned
he's a customs officer that was like
getting bribes mmm yeah I'm an publicist
somebody [ __ ] up in the supply chain
that's really cute when I look at stuff
like that I always wonder like when do
you when do you get that amount of money
and you say cut yeah yeah cuz it's
coming in so easy cuz in my mind from
the outside looking in I'd say once it
hit like 700,000 I would been like too
much I'm done I'm how but why I hate the
mill why not I know I mean when I hit
two mill yeah do they really even like
sometimes a note that line will work
right do they even have a choice at that
point if they're getting paid by
dangerous people like can you even be
like I'm out I'm out of the game good
point or you could set somebody else up
it's like hey I'll set somebody else to
do this instead and I'm out according to
movies i watch you cannot get out of the
game you can't can't get up yeah that's
where all of our college comes to the
movies I also learned about money
laundering from lethal weapon - from Joe
Pesci's character yes cuz he tells you
how do they do it like monkey brain
still think so just people putting money
in dryers oh wow Oh No Jason Bateman is
a [ __ ] genius
though he starts cash businesses and
then he slots in the fake money and then
pays it all out laundering from Breaking
Bad yeah well I think at one point he
actually had money in the dryer I
remember in the show like literally
trying exactly does it got wet Joe
[ __ ] me what do you think got wet in
the show watching me do it [ __ ] Jim
we're trying to clean some [ __ ] up
spoken like an influence
[Music]